हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
प्लीज चैट में बता दीजिए।
एंड फिन कॉम वेरी गुड इवनिंग। प्लीज एक
बार आप फिर से दोबारा आप अपना नाम बता
दोगे बिकॉज़ मैं भूल गया। आई एम रियली सॉरी
फॉर दैट। क्योंकि अगर जो स्टूडेंट्स
क्लासेस में आते हैं अगर मुझे उनका रियल
नेम पता रहेगा तो मैं अगले बार से कोशिश
करूंगा कि आपका रियल नेम से आपको बोलने की
कोशिश करूंगा ताकि आपको भी अच्छा लगे और
मुझे भी अच्छा लगे। तो प्लीज एक बार फिर
से आप मुझे बता दीजिए ताकि मुझे पता रहे
कि एक्चुअल में आपका रियल नेम क्या है।
नोक्स आई नो यू आर अंकित एंड आपका भी नाम
बता दीजिए प्लीज। तो आई होप सबको आवाज
सुनाई दे रही होगी।
दीपशिख आई एम मैं प्रोनाउंसिएशन सही बोल
रहा हूं। दीपशिख
ओके तो वेरी गुड इवनिंग दीपशिख एंड वेरी
गुड इवनिंग अंकित
वेरी गुड इवनिंग तो आई होप कि आपको हमारे
जो टेलीग्राम ग्रुप था जिस जो हमने
क्लासेस नोट्स के लिए बनाया हुआ है
रिसोर्सेज के लिए वहां पर आपको
कोड मिल गया होगा कल की क्लास का कोड मिल
गया होगा मिल गया था सबको
जी जगत गुरु जी हर हर महादेव तो शायद आपको
मिल गया होगा तो तो यह बताइए कि प्रैक्टिस
किसी ने की
पीपीटी मैं शेयर कर दूंगा कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है किसी को प्रीवियस क्लास में कोई
डाउट है किसी को भी
कल की क्लास जो थी उसमें किसी को कोई डाउट
है किसी को कोई कोड समझ में नहीं आया हो
क्योंकि इसमें कुछ समझने वाली तो बात नहीं
थी बिकॉज़ हर हर एक चीज को मैंने लाइन बाय
लाइन स्टेप बाय स्टेप एक्सप्लेन किया है।
तो प्लीज मैं आप लोगों को एक चीज बता देता
हूं कि अगर आपको सच में साइबर सिक्योरिटी
में काम करना है या अपने आपको कैपेबल
बनाना है या कोई भी एग्जाम देना है तो
प्लीज एंड मैं आपको यही चीज बताऊंगा कि
हमेशा प्रैक्टिस कीजिए। प्रैक्टिस को मत
छोड़िए। और जब आप बार-बार प्रैक्टिस
करोगे, प्रैक्टिस करने के बाद क्या होता
है कि आप एक स्टेज पर आते हो। मुझे पता है
कि एक दो बार, तीन बार प्रैक्टिस करने के
बाद जैसे उस चीज को आप फिर से पढ़ते हो तो
आपको लगता है कि
मुझे सब कुछ आता है तो मुझे दोबारा पढ़ने
की जरूरत नहीं है। लेकिन ऐसी बात नहीं है।
आपको जब आपको सब कुछ आता है तो तब आप अपने
नोट्स बनाइए। खुद की भाषा में खुद के
लैंग्वेज में खुद के नोट जैसे आपको समझ
में आता है वैसे आप कहीं पर नोट बना के
रखिए ताकि जब जैसे ही आप वो पर्टिकुलर
पॉइंट को देखोगे तब आपको समझ में आएगा कि
यह कांसेप्ट कहां का था और मुझे कैसे समझ
में आया था तो ऐसे कीजिए तो दीपशिख आप
tlegram इंस्टॉल नहीं किया है तो tlegram
मोबाइल से भी चला सकते हो तो चला लीजिए
क्योंकि आप लोगों के लिए
मैं नोट्स शेयर कर रहा हूं। धीरे-धीरे
आपको मैं जैसे जैसे आपकी क्लासेस खत्म
होती जाएंगी, मैं धीरे-धीरे आपके सामने जो
लेटेस्ट बुक है जो आपको पढ़नी चाहिए एज ए
साइबर सिक्योरिटी स्टूडेंट वो भी मैं आपको
शेयर करना स्टार्ट कर दूंगा। जो काफी
प्रीमियम बुक है जिसके लिए
ठीक है?
जिसके लिए आपको पे करना पड़ता है वो भी
मैं आपको शेयर करने की कोशिश करूंगा। तो
होल्ड ऑन गाइस।
एक मिनट का टाइम दीजिए मुझे।
ओके ओके आई एम बैक। तो चलो अभी सेशन को
स्टार्ट करते हैं। ठीक है? टाइम वेस्ट
नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि जितने स्टूडेंट्स को
आना चाहिए था उन्होंने वो आ चुके हैं। तो
कोई बात नहीं बाकी स्टूडेंट्स मुझे लगता
है शायद रिकॉर्डिंग को देख लेंगे। तो आप
लोगों को बता देता हूं कि फिर भी अगर कोई
स्टूडेंट नया है। मैं आपको एक चीज बता
देता हूं कि हमने टेलीग्राम ग्रुप स्टार्ट
किया है स्पेशली आप लोगों के लिए जिसमें
मैं आपके साथ रिसोर्सेज शेयर कर सकूं।
आपके साथ मैं अपने नोट्स शेयर कर सकूं या
कभी कबभार मैं आपके साथ इंटरेक्शन कर सकूं
क्योंकि मैंने एज एन एडमिन उसको डिसेबल
किया हुआ है कॉल के लिए और वीडियो कॉल के
लिए बट कभी हमें मौका मिलेगा जब मुझे लगता
है कि आप लोगों से बात करनी चाहिए जब आप
लोग चाहोगे या आपके डाउट्स होंगे तो
डेफिनेटली हम कभी कभार वहां पर एक
कॉन्फ्रेंस की कॉल की तरह भी हम वहां पर
बात कर लेंगे ताकि ताकि आपको सही गाइडेंस
मिले। आपको सही सपोर्ट मिले। सब कुछ जो
चीजें आपको चाहिए वो मिलती रहे। तो चलिए
फिर हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। हम चलते
हैं। सबसे पहले हम एनालाइज करते हैं कि
हमने जो प्रीवियस कोड सबको पता होगा हमने
क्या-क्या किया था। तो ये हमारा कोड है।
एक बार देख लेते हैं सब कुछ सेटअप है या
नहीं है। ओके। यह भी हमने लिख रखा है। सही
लिखा है। कॉल अनहाइड कोड हमने लिख लिया
था। ऑटो ओपन के लिए भी कोड कोड लिखा हुआ
है। यह भी परफेक्ट है। अनहाइड का कोड लिखा
हुआ है। गुड। इसके अंदर हमने ओबीजी सेल,
नेटवर्क सेल, कॉल, आइटम ये सारे हमने
चलो परफेक्ट ये भी सही है। देन ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम पॉइंट नंबर वन ओएस डिटेल रिकॉर्न
के लिए भी कोड लिख लिया था। नेटवर्क डिटेल
रिकॉर्न के लिए भी कोड लिख लिया था।
ठीक है? और हमने फिर
थर्ड वन यूजर इनेशन के लिए भी रिकॉर्ड के
लिए एक कोड लिख लिया था। एक कोड और मैं
लिखने वाला हूं। किसके लिए? मैं लिखने
वाला हूं अपने रजिस्ट्री के लिए। ऑटो रन
के अंदर जो सिस्टम ऑन होते ही जो
रजिस्ट्री या जो कोड रन होता है जो
स्क्रिप्ट रन होती है उसके रिगार्डिंग भी
फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं इनेशन। तो उसके
लिए भी मैं एक कोड पेस्ट कर रहा हूं। जो
कल के लिए प्लान नहीं था लेकिन आज मैंने
उसके आपके लिए फाइंड आउट किया है। तो
बिल्कुल सिंपल है। इसमें कुछ खास नहीं है।
तो इसको मैं सिंपल क्या करता हूं? अभी कट
कॉपी पेस्ट कर लेता हूं। तो यहां पर भी हम
क्या कर देते हैं? इसको पेस्ट कर देते
हैं। तो सिंपल है ये रहा। बिल्कुल सिंपल
है। कुछ भी इसमें नया नहीं है। लगभग सेम
ही है। तो यहां पर लिखा हमने रजिस्ट्री
चेक। सिक्योरिटी रजिस्ट्री चेक
पर्सिस्टेंस और ऑटो रन वाली। इसका भी
रिकॉर्ड करने वाले हैं। यहां पर देखो
रजिस्ट्री ऑटो स्टार्ट चेक। रन कीज यह
कमेंट है। यह भी हमें फंक्शन के अंदर
टेक्स्ट हमने प्रोवाइड किया है। ऑन एरर
रिज्यूम नेक्स्ट यह क्या है कि अगर
ड्यूरिंग रजिस्ट्री चेक अगर कोई
प्रिविलजेस मांगती है वो रजिस्ट्री का
एक्सेस नहीं मिलता। आपको ऐसे आप ऐसे यूजर
से एक्सेस कर पा आप ऐसे यूजर को दिया
जिसके पास कुछ भी प्रिविलजेस नहीं है।
बहुत ही मिनिमम है। पर उसके कारण कोई भी
एरर आती है तो ये बोल रहा है कि कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। अगर एरर आती है
स्क्रिप्ट को क्रैश नहीं करना है। आपको
नेक्स्ट लाइन ऑफ कोड पे चला जाना है। उस
एरर को हम बाद में देख लेंगे। उसके बाद
हमने क्या किया? रन की पाथ एज अ स्ट्रिंग।
एक यहां पे एक वेरिएबल दिया। यहां पर हमने
रजिस्ट्री का पाथ सेट किया। उसके बाद हम
क्या करते हैं? चेक करते हैं इस पाथ के
ऊपर कि इस पाथ के ऊपर कौन-कौन सी डिफॉल्ट
वैल्यू सेट है। तो यहां पर बिल्कुल सिंपल
कोड है। कुछ भी डिफरेंट कोड नहीं है। चलो
यहां तक तो सब कुछ आपको पता चल गया होगा
कि हम चार इनेशन फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं।
सबसे पहला ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की इनेशन।
दूसरा हम फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं यूजर की
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन। तीसरी रजिस्ट्री के अंदर
इनेशन फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं। चौथी चीज हम
क्या कर रहे हैं? नेटवर्क की डिटेल
डिटेल्स हम फाइंड आउट कर रहे हैं। और
अगर आप लोगों को याद होगा कि यह सारी
डिटेल मैं कहां पर स्टोर कर रहा हूं? ये
सारी डिटेल नेटवर्क की स्पेलिंग रॉन्ग है।
वे द नेटवर्क?
कोई नहीं। कोई नहीं। कमेंट में नेटवर्क की
स्पेलिंग रोंग है ना?
कोई बात नहीं। वेरी गुड। चलो हमने कर दिया
चेंज। तो अभी आप लोगों ने एक चीज नोटिस की
होगी। भले ही हमने क्या किया यहां पर
कितना सारा डेटा हैंडल कर रहे हैं लेकिन
सारा डेटा कहां पर आ रहा है? इस फंक्शन के
अंदर। सारा डेटा इस फंक्शन के अंदर आ रहा
है। इस फंक्शन के कहां पर स्टोर हो रहा
है? रिपोर्ट डेटा नाम के वेरिएबल के अंदर।
बेसिकली ये जो भी रिकॉर्ड डेटा है वो एक
वेरिएबल में स्टोर किया जा रहा है मेमोरी
के अंदर। और आपके टारगेट सिस्टम पर। आई एम
रिपीटिंग अगेन। जो भी रिकॉर्ड डाटा आप
कलेक्ट कर रहे हो सारे रिकॉर्ड डाटा को आप
क्या कर रहे हो? आपके टारगेट सिस्टम के
अंदर उसकी मेमोरी में एक वेरिएबल के फॉर्म
में या एक वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर कर रहे
हो। ठीक है? आप एक वेरिएबल के अंदर टारगेट
सिस्टम के अंदर उसकी मेमोरी में वो सारा
रिकॉर्ड डेटा स्टोर कर रहे हो। ठीक है? अब
हमें क्या करना है? नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा
क्या है? सबको पता है नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा
क्या है? नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा है कि जो
सारा टेक्स्ट डेटा है मैं इस सारे टेक्स्ट
डेटा को जो भी रिकॉर्ड डेटा मैंने कलेक्ट
किया है मैं अपनी काली लinक्स मशीन पर
चाहिए मुझे मैं अपनी काली लinक्स मशीन के
साथ शेयर करना चाहता हूं या अपनी काली
लinक्स मशीन के ऊपर ट्रांसमिट करना चाहता
हूं अब वो कैसे पॉसिबल है वो कैसे पॉसिबल
है ये आपको पता है कि जो लास्ट सिनेरियो
हमने बात किया था जो लास्ट सिनेरियो था
हमने डिस्कस किया था उसमें हमने क्या किया
था। अटैकर मशीन के साथ कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश
किया था। किसकी हेल्प से? पावर सेल कमांड
की हेल्प से। तो सेम तरीके से हम भी इसमें
क्या करने वाले हैं? लास्ट सिनेरियो की
तरह ही हम पावर सेल का यूज़ करेंगे। और
पावर सेल का यूज़ करते हुए हम
जो आपकी अटैकर मशीन है, जो आपकी लinक्स
मशीन है, जो काली लinक्स है, उसके साथ
क्या करेंगे?
टीसीp कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश करेंगे। लेकिन
यह सारे काम करते वक्त आपको एक चीज का
ध्यान रखना है और वह क्या है? जब भी हम हम
क्या करते हैं कि वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट के
अंदर कोई भी टेक्स्ट पावर सेल को पास करते
हैं। वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर कोई भी
टेक्स्ट पावर सेल को पास करते हैं तो वहां
पर आपको एक बहुत ही जरूरी बात को ध्यान
में रखना है। आपको बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है
जिसको ध्यान में रखना है और वो क्या है?
उस टेक्स्ट के अंदर कोई भी सिंगल कोड नहीं
बनना चाहिए। उस टेक्स्ट के अंदर कोई भी
सिंगल कोट नहीं बनना चाहिए। और यह सिंगल
कोट अक्सर कब बनता है? खासकर यह तब बनता
है जब आप कोई नेम का कलेक्शन कर रहे हो या
कोई फाइल पाथ का कलेक्शन कर रहे हो। उस
केस में क्या होता है कि आपका जो सिंगल
कोर्स है वो आपको देखने को मिल सकता है।
अब आप बोल रहे हो कि ठीक है सर सिंगल कोट
नहीं बनना चाहिए। सर अगर उस डेटा में
सिंगल कोट बन रहा है तो क्या होगा सर? अगर
मैं उसको डायरेक्टली पावर सेल को पास कर
दूं तो क्या होगा? बन रहा है। अगर सिंगल
कोट बन रहा है तो उसको मैं डायरेक्टली
पावर सेल को पास कर दूंगा। तो क्या होगा?
पावर सेल सोचेगा कि जो कमांड लाइन कमांड
में आपने डेटा पास किया है जो टेक्स्ट
डेटा पास किया है तो जो सिंगल कोट्स होते
हैं जो डबल कोट्स होते हैं वो बहुत
ज्यादाेंट होते हैं और वो क्या कर सकते
हैं आपकी जो कमांड है उसको ब्रेक कर सकते
हैं और जब कमांड ब्रेक होगी तो सिंटेक्स
एरर आएगी सिंटेक्स एरर आएगी तो क्या होगा
आपकी स्क्रिप्ट क्या है क्रैश हो सकती है
फॉर एग्जांपल मैं आपको इसका एक डमी डमी
नहीं है ये रियल है कि जो एक रिकॉन टेस्ट
मैंने आप लोगों के लिए पहले से चलाया था।
तो जो वेरिएबल में डेटा स्टोर हो रहा है
ना वो इस तरीके से वेरिएबल में डेटा स्टोर
हो रहा है। सेम जो वेरिएबल है उस वेरिएबल
के अंदर जो डेटा स्टोर हो रहा है रिपोर्ट
डेटा के अंदर इस तरीके से स्टोर हो रहा
है।
स्टील सिस्टम रिपोर्ट जनरेटेड ऑन होस्ट
नेम करंट यूजर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम नेम वर्जन
आर्किटेक्चर रजिस्टर्ड यूजर इंस्टॉल डेट
फिर मैक एड्रेस आईपी एड्रेस एडप्टर
डिस्क्रिप्शन मैक एड्रेस इस तरीके से सारा
डेटा आपका लाइन बाय लाइन स्टोर हो रहा है।
ये वो डेटा है जो आपके मेमोरी के अंदर उस
वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर हो रहा है। ओके।
अभी आप एक चीज नोटिस करोगे। क्या यहां
कहीं पर भी सिंगल कोट आ रहा है?
कहीं पर भी स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर सिंगल कोट आ
रहा है। कहीं पर भी इस स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर
कोई भी सिंगल कोट आ रहा है? बताओ।
सिंगल कोट आ रहा है।
सिंगल कोट आ रहा है भाई। होस्ट नेम में
देखो। ओ सिंगल कोट स्टूडेंट है ना यहां पर
देखो ध्यान से देखो जो मैंने हाईलाइट किया
है सिंगल कोट आ रहा है बाकी पूरी
स्क्रिप्ट में कहीं पर नहीं है लेकिन यहां
पर होस्ट नेम में सिंगल कोट बन रहा है जिस
चीज का डर था वो यहां पर बन रहा है ठीक है
वहां यहां पर बन रहा है तो अगर इस डेटा को
एज इट इज पास कर दिया किसको आपके पावर सेल
को क्योंकि पावर सेल में आप क्या करने
वाले हो एक वेर वेरिएबल के अंदर इस
टेक्स्ट डेटा को क्या करने वाले हो? सेव
करने वाले हो। उसके बाद जो आपको ट्रांसलेट
कन्वर्शन करना है वो करोगे। लेकिन पहले आप
पावर सेल के अंदर भी एक वेरिएबल के अंदर
इस डेटा को सेव करने वाले हो। कॉपी करने
वाले हो या उसका रेफरेंस रखने वाले हो। और
मैं मेरी कंडीशन ये है कि अगर फॉर
एग्जांपल देखो पावर सेल ऐसे रीड किया।
यहां तक रीड किया। यहां से रीड करते क्या
हो जाएगी? कमांड ब्रेक हो जाएगी। पावर सेल
समझेगा कि सिंगल कोट हो गया। तो मेरा
टेक्स्ट यहीं तक था। यह और कुछ है इसके
आगे जिसकी वजह से हुआ क्या है? यह तो कोई
ना तो कोई कमांड है ना कोई डेटा है नथिंग
उसके लिए कुछ नहीं है। कमांड ब्रेक होगी।
यहां पर सिंटेक्स एरर आएगा। यहां पर
सिंटेक्स एरर आएगा। तो इसी चीज को अवॉइड
करने के लिए हमें क्या करना है? हम एक
मेथड का यूज़ कर सकते हैं। इस चीज को अवॉइड
करने के लिए एक मेथड का यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
वो मेथड कौन सा है आपका? रिप्लेस मेथड।
रिप्लेस मेथड क्या करता है? रिप्लेस मेथड
इस पूरे टेक्स्ट को एनालाइज करेगा। पूरे
टेक्स्ट को रीड करेगा और पूरे टेक्स्ट को
रीड करने के बाद उसके अंदर क्या करेगा?
उसके अंदर सिंगल कोट को ढूंढेगा। क्योंकि
वहां पर हम मेंशन करेंगे कि किस चीज को
हमें ढूंढना है और उसको अगर वो चीज मिलती
है उस डेटा के अंदर किस चीज के साथ उसको
रिप्लेस करना है। ये सारी चीजें हम उसके
अंदर मेंशन करेंगे। तो वो क्या करेगा? उस
पूरे टेक्स्ट के अंदर कहां-कहां पर सिंगल
कोट आया है या यूज़ हुआ है। ठीक है? वो
उसको फाइंड आउट करेगा। और जैसे ही उसको
सिंगल कोट मिलेगा वो उस सिंगल कोट को डबल
सिंगल कोट के साथ क्या कर देगा? रिप्लेस
कर देगा। जिससे क्या होगा? हमारा जो हमारा
जो
स्क्रिप्ट है हमारी जो स्क्रिप्ट है वो
क्रैश होने से बच जाएगी। हम कैसे यूज़ कर
सकते हैं? तो इसको यूज़ करने के लिए मैं
ऑलरेडी एक वेरिएबल्स तो क्रिएट कर चुका
हूं। यहां पर ऊपर देखोगे यहां पर एस्केप
रिपोर्ट के नाम से एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट किया
हुआ है। तो इसके अंदर अभी हम वो डेटा
स्टोर करेंगे जिसमें जिस चीज का डर था वो
अवॉइड करने के लिए। तो चलो फिर हम क्या
करते हैं? एस्केप रिपोर्ट इक्वल साइन
रिप्लेस
रिप्लेस मेथड का हमने यहां पर यूज़ किया।
देन उसके बाद हम क्या देखेंगे? रिपोर्ट
डाटा।
रिपोर्ट डाटा। आई होप यही होना चाहिए।
उसके बाद हमने क्या बोला? डबल कोट के अंदर
हम मेंशन कर रहे हैं सिंगल कोट।
डबल कोट क्योंकि सिंगल कोट आपको फाइंड आउट
करना है। किसके साथ रिप्लेस करना है। उसके
बाद आपको
ये इसके साथ रिप्लेस करना है। ये बन गया
आपका कोड। और एक काम चेक करते हैं।
रिपोर्ट डाटा को चेक कर लेते हैं ऊपर जाकर
कि क्या यह वेरिएबल सही है या गलत है। तो
अब यह हम इसको कॉपी कर लेंगे और इसको
रिप्लेस भी कर लेंगे अगर कोई इशू होगा तो।
तो चलिए फिर ये हो गया। तो ये वो मेथड है।
क्या करेगा? ये पूरे टेक्स्ट को पूरे
टेक्स्ट में सिंगल कोट को ढूंढेगा और
सिंगल कोट को ढूंढने के बाद उसको किस में
कन्वर्ट करेगा? दो सिंगल कोड्स के अंदर
कन्वर्ट कर देगा। जिससे जो हमारी
स्क्रिप्ट है जो पावर सेल की स्क्रिप्ट है
वो क्रैश होने से बच जाएगी। वो क्या हो
जाएगी? आपकी पावर सेल की स्क्रिप्ट क्रैश
होने से बच जाएगी। ओके तो चलिए अब एक काम
और कर लेते हैं। अभी हम IP एड्रेस और
मेंशन कर लेते हैं एक बार। सॉरी आईपी
एड्रेस अभी मेंशन नहीं करा बट मैं यहां पर
लिख लेता हूं। ठीक है? तो चलो फिर अटैकर
आईपी
अटैकर आईपी इक्वल
यहां पर हम लिख लेते हैं कुछ भी अभी मैं
119 डॉट नहीं 168.19
वैसे ही लिख लेता हूं। 134 था शायद लास्ट
टाइम मेरा IP 134 इट्स ओके मैं अभी लिख
लेता हूं। नेक्स्ट हम क्या लिख लेते हैं?
अटैकर पोर्ट
अटैकर पोर्ट क्योंकि हमें कनेक्शन भी
बनाना है। तो कनेक्शन बनाने के लिए हम यूज़
करेंगे 44 44। ओके? इसको भी हम डबल कोट के
अंदर रखने वाले हैं। ठीक? ये भी हमने रख
लिया। तो यहां तक हमने स्क्रिप्ट को लिख
लिया। यहां तक हमने स्क्रिप्ट को लिख
लिया। यहां तक शायद हमारी स्क्रिप्ट
कंप्लीट हो चुकी है। लगभग नहीं हुई। अभी
एक्चुअल मैजिक है वह
आपका
जो लॉजिक है अभी स्टार्ट होता है। तो चलो
हम पीपीटी पर चलते हैं। ठीक है? अभी मुझे
क्या करना है? अभी मुझे एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन
करना है। अभी मुझे क्या करना है? मुझे
डेटा को ट्रांसफर करना है अपनी म अटैकर
मशीन के ऊपर। तो हम कैसे कर सकते हैं? वो
करने के लिए हमें कुछ पांच से छह स्टेप्स
को फॉलो करना पड़ेगा। सबसे पहला स्टेप
क्या है? सबसे पहले हम यूज़ करेंगे पावर
सेल को। ठीक है? सबसे पहले स्टेप में हम
यूज़ करेंगे। हम क्या करेंगे? लॉन्च द पावर
सेल इंजन इन द बैकग्राउंड विद हिडन विंडोज
एट्रिब्यूट एंड इंश्योरिंग नो ग्राफिकल
पॉप अप अलर्ट दैट द टारगेट यूजर। सबसे
पहले आपको क्या करना है? पावर सेल को
बैकग्राउंड में साइलेंटली रन करना है।
बिना कोई यूजर कोई ग्राफिकल पॉप अप किए
हुए या बिना कोई यूजर को अलर्ट किए हुए।
दूसरा काम आपको क्या करना है? जो डेटा
आपने कलेक्ट किया उसको पावर सेल के अंदर
एक वेरिएबल में स्टोर करना है। ठीक है? जो
डेटा आपने कलेक्ट किया उसको एक वेरिएबल के
अंदर क्या करना है? स्टोर किया है। तीसरी
चीज आपको क्या करनी है? अभी हमारे पास
डेटा है टेक्स्ट स्ट्रिंग में। ठीक है?
हमारे पास जो डेटा है वो ह्यूमन रीडेबल
टेक्स्ट स्ट्रिंग डेटा है। उसको हमें
कन्वर्ट करना है किसके अंदर? रो बाइनरी
बाइट के अंदर। क्योंकि जो आपके नेटवर्क
सॉकेट्स है वो टेक्स्ट डेटा को नहीं
समझती। वो सिर्फ बाइनरी डेटा को समझती है।
बाइनरी बाइट्स को समझती है। इसलिए हमें
क्या करना पड़ेगा? नेटवर्क के ऊपर
ट्रांसमिशन करने के लिए हमें उस ह्यूमन
रीडेबल डेटा को या ह्यूमन रिडेबल टेक्स्ट
स्ट्रिंग को हमें क्या करना है? कन्वर्ट
करना है बाइनरी के अंदर। ये तीसरा टास्क
रहेगा हमारा।
चौथा टास्क हमारा क्या है? हम टीसीपी
कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश करेंगे टैकर मशीन के
साथ। पांचवा हमारे पास क्या है? हम उसके
बाद डेटा ट्रांसमिशन करेंगे। और जब एक बार
हमने डेटा ट्रांसमिशन कर दिया। जैसे कि
हमने लास्ट क्लास में किया था। जब हमने एक
बार डाटा ट्रांसमिशन कर दिया उसके बाद हम
नेटवर्क कनेक्शन को बंद कर देंगे ताकि
उसके कोई भी ट्रेसेस ना बचे। तो बेसिकली
मोटे-मोटे हमने छह स्टेप करने हैं। पावर
सेल का यूज़ करना है। चुपचाप डेटा को हमें
एक वेरिएबल में स्टोर करना है। उसके बाद
उस डेटा को बाइनरी बाइट में कन्वर्ट करना
है। उसके बाद टीसीp कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश
करना है। उसके बाद फिर डेटा ट्रांसमिशन
करना है। डाटा ट्रांसफर होने के बाद फिर
उस कनेक्शन को क्लोज करना है। सॉकेट को
क्लोज करना है।
ठीक है तो आपको एक चीज मोटा मोटा पता चल
गया
ठीक है ये आपको
उसका भी एक्सप्लेनेशन आपको मिलूंगा मैं आप
लोग क्या है ना किसी चीज को गलत समझते हो
मैंने एक स्टिल्थी वर्ड यूज़ किया ना तो
उसका आप आपका मतलब आप उसको समझ रहे हो कि
नहीं बिल्कुल किसी को पता ना चले उसको भी
हमें एग्जीक्यूटिव समरी के अंदर
लोग तो आप मैं एक चीज बता दूंगा कि
Windows के अंदर चाहे आप कुछ भी करो कुछ
भी करो हर एक चीज का लोग बनता है।
Windows के अंदर आप कुछ भी करो हर एक चीज
का लोग बनता है। ठीक है? यह मत सोचो कि
लोग नहीं बनेगा। लोग बनता है। हमारा काम
है
भीड़ के साथ निकलना। बट मैं आपको इतना
एडवांस नहीं पढ़ा रहा कि
कि जो आप बिल्कुल आज के बाद जो भी पेलोड
बनाओगे आप पूरे हाईली इवज पे लोड बनाओगे
ऐसा नहीं है। फिर भी मैं आपको एनहांस कर
रहा हूं आपके बिल्कुल बेसिक से थोड़े से
ऊपर लेवल पर। ठीक है? तो नेक्स्ट उसके लिए
हम कौन सी कमांड यूज़ करने वाले हैं? हम
पावर सेलxc विंडो स्टाइल हिडन। उसके बाद
यहां पर हमारी सारी कमांड्स आएंगी। ओके?
उसके बाद जैसे मैंने आपको बताया एक
टेक्स्ट नाम का हम वेरिएबल क्रिएट करेंगे।
उस वेरिएबल के अंदर हम उस टेक्स्ट डेटा को
कौन से टेक्स्ट डेटा को जो हमने सिंग उसके
बाद रिप्लेस मेथड के बाद उसको कन्वर्ट
किया ना जो रिप्लेस मेथड का यूज़ किया उसके
बाद एक वेरिएबल में डेटा स्टोर किया उस
डेटा को यहां पर हमने एक टेक्स्ट नाम के
वेरिएबल में स्टोर कर लिया। उसके बाद जैसा
कि आपको पता है हमें एक ट्रांसलेटर चाहिए।
हमें एक ट्रांसलेटर चाहिए उस टेक्स्ट को
कन्वर्ट करने के लिए बाइनरी बाइट के अंदर।
तो चलिए फिर यहां पर हम यूज़ करते हैं ये
रहा। ये सारे वेरिएबल्स हैं सिस्टम डॉट
टेक्स्ट डॉट इनकोडिंग। ये क्या करता है?
यह एक बिल्ट इन डॉट नेटवर्क फ्रेमवर्क
क्लास है जिसका यूज किया जाता है जिसको
डिजाइन किया गया है
कई तरह की इनकोडिंग्स को हैंडल करने के
लिए। ठीक है? इसका जो डिजाइन किया गया है
जिसको बनाया गया है इसको अलग-अलग कररेक्टर
इनकोडिंग को हैंडल करने के लिए बनाया गया
है। जैसे कि एसकाई टू यूएफ 8 या यूनिकोड।
ठीक है? तो बेसिकली ये क्या है? आपकी एक
डॉट नेट फ्रेमवर्क की क्लास है जिसका मेन
पर्पस है कैरेक्टर इनकोडिंग्स को हैंडल
करना। ठीक है? या स्काई टू यूटीएफ 8 या
यूनिकोड। उसके बाद हमने ये डबल डबल कॉलन
यूटीएफ एट हमने मेंशन किया है। तो इसका
मतलब क्या है कि हम यहां पर वो स्पेसिफाई
करें कि भैया इस केस में हम यूज़ करना करने
वाले हैं यूटीएफ एट इनकोडिंग का। ठीक है?
हमारे डेटा को कन्वर्ट करने के लिए हम किस
में कन्वर्ट करना चाहते हैं हम? यूटीएफ 8
इनकोडिंग के अंदर। उसके बाद आता है हमारा
डॉट गेट बाइट। और यहां पर हमने मेंशन किया
है क्या? हमारा टेक्स्ट। यहां पर मेंशन
किया हमने टेक्स्ट। ये क्या करता है? ए
मेथड दैट टेक्स आवर कंप्लीट टेक्स्ट
स्ट्रिंग एंड कन्वर्ट इट इंटू ए रो बाइट
अरे। बेसिकली क्या करता है? जो हमारा
टेक्स्ट डेटा है उसको पूरे टेक्स्ट डेटा
को क्या करता है? उठाता है। एक बाइट अरे
में कन्वर्ट कर देता है ताकि उसको नेटवर्क
पर ट्रांसमिट किया जा सके। क्या किसके
अंदर कन्वर्ट करता है? बाइट अरे के अंदर।
बेसिकली यहां पर किसके अंदर कन्वर्ट किया
जा रहा है? अरे के अंदर। अंडरस्टुड गाइस?
यहां पर अरे के अंदर उसको कन्वर्ट किया जा
रहा है। तो एक चीज का ध्यान रखना सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट रूल है। यहां पर आप इसको स्टार
कर लीजिए। आपको नोट डाउन कर लीजिए।
जब भी आप कोई भी एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन करना
चाहते हो खासकर डाटा के डाटा एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन और डाटा एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन में
आप किसका यूज कर रहे हो नेटवर्क सॉकेट
प्रोग्रामिंग का नेटवर्क सॉकेट
प्रोग्रामिंग का या टीसीपी क्लाइंट का तो
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट या सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
क्या है कि
आपका जो टेक्स्ट डेटा है उसको हमेशा रो
बाइट्स में कन्वर्ट करना है। यह एक
मैंडेटरी है। आप इसको बोल सकते हो इट इज ए
मैंडेटरी स्किल कि आपका जो डेटा है, आपका
जो टेक्स्ट डेटा है उसको डेटा स्ट्रीम पर
राइट करने से पहले नेटवर्क स्ट्रीम पर
राइट करने से पहले हमेशा आपके टेक्स्ट
डेटा को रो बाइनरी बाइट्स के अंदर या रो
बाइनरी डेटा के अंदर कन्वर्ट करना है। अगर
आप ऐसा नहीं करोगे तो क्या होगा?
आपका जो कनेक्शन है उसमें एरर आएंगे और
एरर आने की वजह से आपका कनेक्शन फेल हो
जाएगा। तो यह चीज आपको याद रखना है।
देखो
दीपशिख
आप Windows के अंदर जो भी कुछ मैक्सिमम
करते हो उसमें नेट फ्रेमवर्क का ही यूज़
करते हो। ज्यादातर क्योंकि Windows ने
आपके लिए बनाया हुआ है। अगर नेट फ्रेमवर्क
की क्लासेस का यूज नहीं करोगे तो आप सोचो
कि आप सी या सी शार्प में ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
लेवल पर या मशीन मशीन लैंग्वेज में ये
टास्क आप खुद को लिखना पड़ेगा। कैसे
लिखोगे? क्योंकि वो तो चीज आपको आती ही
नहीं। एक चीज बताई है जो चीज आपको
प्रोवाइड की हुई है। आपको उसी का यूज करना
है रेदर देन कि आप खुद से कुछ लिखने लग
जाए। बिकॉज़ हिट एंड ट्रायल करते रहोगे और
आपके महीनों निकल जाएंगे। सिर्फ ये एक
सिंपल सा टास्क परफॉर्म करने के लिए जिसके
लिए एक लाइब्रेरी एक क्लास ऑलरेडी अवेलेबल
है किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर।
अंडरस्टुड?
तो यहां तक हो गया। नेक्स्ट उसके बाद हमें
ये यहां पर हमने टीसीp कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश
किया क्योंकि यहां पर हमने बाइट्स में
कन्वर्ट कर लिया। ये हमारा टेक्स्ट डेटा
था। उसके बाद सबको याद है। यहां पर हम
किसके अंदर क्या कर रहे हैं? यहां पर हम
एक टीसीp कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश किया। उसके
बाद स्ट्रीम सेटअप किया। स्ट्रिप को
कॉन्फ़िगर किया। स्ट्रीम कॉन्फ़िगर करने के
बाद हमने उसको उसके बाद डेटा को राइट
किया। राइट करने के बाद स्ट्रीम को क्लोज
कर दिया। सॉकेट को भी क्लोज कर दिया। ये
चीज आपको पहले से ही पता होगा। ये चीज
आपको पहले से ही पता होगी। यह मैं आपको
दोबारा बताने की जरूरत नहीं है। किसी को
दोबारा बताने की जरूरत है? प्लीज बताइए।
नहीं है ना जरूरत बताने की? बताओ।
शायद नहीं होगी जरूरत।
चलिए तो यह आपका फाइनल पेलोड है। यह आपका
फाइनल पावर सेल कमांड है। यह आपका फाइनल
पेलोड है जो हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं। तो चलो
इसको भी हम कॉपी कर लेते हैं। तो कॉपी
कहां से करेंगे? यहां से। तो मैंने ऑलरेडी
लिखा हुआ है ये रहा।
तो चलो फिर इसको भी कॉपी कर लेते हैं और
वहां पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं। किसके अंदर?
ये रहा। तो चलो कॉपी एंड पेस्ट लिख दिया
यहां पर मैंने
और इसके लिए मैं आपको लिए एक कमेंट मेंशन
कर देता हूं ताकि आप लोगों को पता चल जाए
कि यह चीज किस चीज के बारे में है। तो यह
है आपका
पावर सेल
इन मेमोरी
डेटा एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन।
चलो आई होप कि आपको पता चल गया होगा। और
जो यहां पर मैं मेंशन करता हूं एक और
कमेंट मेंशन कर देता हूं ताकि एक और चीज
का आपको आईडिया मिल जाए। यह क्या है आपका
टारगेट
नेटवर्क कॉन्फिगरेशन
यह सेम आईपी आपको यूज नहीं करना है
क्योंकि आपको अपनी काली लinक्स का आईपी
एड्रेस यूज़ करना है। कहीं पर मेरा IPपी
एड्रेस यूज़ करके फिर बोलो सर हमारी जो
रिपोर्ट है वो क्रैश कर रही है। ठीक है?
यहां पर मैं क्या कर रहा हूं? वो सिंगल
कोट वाला काम कर रहा हूं। उसके बाद यहां
पर हमने क्या कर दिया? यहां तक हो गया
हमारा काम पीS एक्स फिल। तो एक काम करते
हैं। इसको भी मैं चेक कर लेता हूं कि यह
जो वेरिएबल है वेरिएबल नेम हमारा गलत नहीं
होना चाहिए। अदरवाइज एरर हम संभाल नहीं
पाएंगे क्योंकि वहां पर हमारा टाइम वेस्ट
बहुत ज्यादा हो जाएगा।
बिल्कुल परफेक्ट है। एंड ये रहा
परफेक्ट है। और बिल्कुल सेम कोड है। इसमें
कुछ भी अंतर नहीं है। विंडो स्टाइल हिडन
है। ये सेम स्केप रिपोर्ट्स ऑन सो ये सब
कुछ यहां पर सेम है। उसके बाद हम क्या
करते हैं? स्क्रिप्ट को क्लीन अप भी करते
हैं। ठीक है? क्योंकि जरूरी है क्लीन अप
करना। नेक्स्ट चलो
ओबीj सेल
इक्वल टू नथिंग
नथिंग
उसके बाद सेट
नेटवर्क नथिंग
सेट
सर्विस
स्पेलिंग एरर हो तो प्लीज बताना मेरे को
बिकॉज़ गड़बड़ हो सकती है।
नथिंग चलो यहां तक हमारी स्क्रिप्ट एंड हो
जाएगी।
चलो चलो यहां तक यह रहा।
और एक बार इन वेरिएबल के नाम से हम क्रॉस
चेक कर लेते हैं ताकि कोई भी प्रॉब्लम ना
हो।
परफेक्ट
तो अब तक किसी को स्क्रिप्ट में डाउट है
तो प्लीज
पूछिए।
ओके और एक बार हम क्या करते हैं?
स्क्रिप्ट को पूरा रिवाइज कर लेते हैं।
यहां पर हमने फंक्शन कॉल किया। कॉल अनहाइड
इनिशिएट फुल रिकॉन कर चुके हैं। उसके बाद
कॉल अनहाइड इनिशिएट फुल रिकॉन यह भी सब
कुछ सही है। अनहाइड का फंक्शन में भी सब
कुछ सही है। देन यह भी परफेक्ट है। कहीं
पर ऐसा तो नहीं है। हम सब कुछ कॉल कर चुके
हैं। चल एक बार आप लोग भी देखना। कहीं पर
भी आपको लगता है कि एरर हो सकती है, आ
सकती है। प्लीज पॉप अप।
तो हमने काफी कोड लिख लिया है।
है ना? अनएक्सेक्टेड कोड लिखा हमने। तो
चलो हमने इतना कुछ कोड लिखा है। तो इसको
एक काम कर देते हैं। अभी क्लोज करते हैं
और शेयर करेंगे। करें क्लोज। क्लोज करते
हैं इसको डॉक्यूमेंट को और शेयर भी
करेंगे। सेव डॉक्यूमेंट को मैं सेव कर
लेता हूं। इसको मिनिमाइज कर देते हैं।
यहां तक का हमारा काम हो गया है। और मशीन
को हम ऑन कर लेते हैं। अभी टारगेट मशीन को
क्योंकि हमें तो टारगेट मशीन तो उधर ही
मिलेगी।
हमें टारगेट मशीन तो इधर ही मिलेगी ना।
चलो कल नेक्स्ट को ऑन करते हैं।
जब तक पहले कोड एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होगा तब
तक कोई फायदा नहीं है आगे बढ़ने का।
इसकी हमेशा वही प्रॉब्लम है। इसको रिस्ट
करते रहो। रिस्ट करते रहो।
यही तो इशू है अभी देखो
पहले मैं एक काम कर लेता हूं इसको शट डाउन
नहीं कर देता हूं। बाद में करते हैं इसका
जो भी कुछ है।
ओह माय गॉड
[हंसी]
ये क्या हो गया?
अनएक्सेक्टेड
विंडो की सबसे बड़ी प्रॉब्लम है। सडनली
सरप्राइजिस पास करती है हमेशा।
करती है ना?
या नहीं करती बताओ।
इट्स ओके। आज हमारे मुझे लगता है ज्यादा
टाइम वेस्ट नहीं होगा हमारा क्योंकि
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हमने अपनी जो
स्क्रिप्ट है पूरी लिख ली। उसका
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन देखना है और वह
करना है। तो मुझे एक चीज और बताओ कि जब यह
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स की जो सारी क्लासेस
कंप्लीट हो जाएंगी तब आपको किस टॉपिक पर
चाहिए बताओ?
मतलब इसके बाद जो नेक्स्ट इसी सेम मॉड्यूल
के अंदर आपको किस टॉपिक पर चाहिए? मैं तो
सोच रहा था कि आपको
ठीक है मैं तो आप लोगों के लिए सोच रहा था
पहले एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग ही कंप्लीट
करवा दूं लेकिन आप लोग चाहोगे और कुछ
ओके लेटरल मूवमेंट एंड पर्सिस्टेंस चाहिए
पर्सिस्टेंस तो ओके आई विल ट्राई लेटरल
मूवमेंट एंड प्रिविलेजेस के लेसन चलेगा
क्योंकि उसके बाद फिर मैं कोशिश करूंगा कि
ऑथेंटिक ेशन अटैक्स या सेशन अटैक्स सेशन
मैनेजमेंट अटैक्स पढ़ाने की कोशिश चाह रहा
था मैं आप लोगों को
नहीं ये कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोड सेव
होगा नो इशू
ये हो जाएगा तब तक के लिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यह बड़ी प्रॉब्लम है किस की
काली के
दोस्त मेरे पढ़ाए हुए थोड़े अलग होते हैं।
अगर नहीं पता तो कोशिश कर लेना मैं ज्यादा
मैच नहीं करता।
क्योंकि मैं जब पढ़ाता हूं तो बिल्कुल
10थ स्टार्टिंग से पढ़ाऊंगा बिल्कुल और
उसको फिर एक लेवल पर ले जाकर छोड़ देता
हूं। अंडरस्टुड
मैं इसकी वो कर देता हूं। धड़कन बढ़ा देता
हूं। टर्बो मोड एक्टिवेट कर देता हूं आज
मेरे लैपटॉप का मैं।
फैन फुल ऑन 10 [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आई वांट टू सी माय लैपटॉप्स।
टर्बो फैन इज ओपनिंग गुड।
जीपीू
कितनी स्पीड पर चल रहा है? गुड।
परफेक्ट।
तो चलो।
ओके विंडो भी अपडेट हो गया।
अरे यार ये क्या करना चाहता है?
माय गॉड मैंने सिर्फ अपनी सेम मशीन को
रेप्लिका किया हुआ है इधर। पता है मेरी जो
सेम मशीन है जो मैं फिजिकल मशीन रन कर रहा
हूं उसको रेप्लिका किया हुआ है इधर।
यह पता नहीं क्या कर
ओके बच गया बच गया बच गया बच गया क्या
इमेज लगा दिया इसने कुछ दिखाई नहीं दे रहा
इसके क्या कलर है नाइट विज़ ऑन कर देते हैं
एंड
डिस्प्ले डिस्प्ले
एंड विद
इसको एक काम कर देता हूं
डिस्प्ले सेटिंग तो यही है। वेस्ट
कहां पर करेंगे इसमें? चेंज
पर्सनलाइज योर एक्सपीरियंस नाउ
ओ माय गॉड आई
ओ हो अपडेट तो था
ओके इससे काम चला लें अभी
इससे काम चला लें। आइकॉन का साइज बढ़ा
देता हूं मैं।
लार्ज आइकॉन।
इससे काम चलाने की कोशिश करते हैं। ठीक
है? मैं इसको डिलीट कर देता हूं। एक फाइल
को। यहां से हम कॉपी कर लेंगे।
उसके बाद मैं रिफ्रेश करता हूं। यह अरेंज
हो गया। और इसका बैकग्राउंड चेंज मैं नहीं
कर पाऊंगा। आई थिंक। एंड क्योंकि
बैकग्राउंड करने की परमिशन अलव नहीं कर
रहा।
एंड थीम हम चेंज कर सकते हैं क्या?
कुछ एक्टिवेट विंडो नाउ।
व्हाट द इशू वि दैट यार?
अपडेट हुआ तो लाइसेंस अपडेट हो गया। चलो
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं।
तो हम एक काम करते हैं। इस फाइल को उठाते
हैं जो हमने बनाई थी। ठीक है? इसको क्लोज
कर देते हैं। हमारी फाइल थी डॉक्यूमेंट्स
के अंदर।
एंड ये रही ये रही।
इज माय फाइल।
ग्लोबल बैंक प्रोफाइल कंट्रोल इसको एक
कॉपी ले जाता हूं। यहां पर यहां पर पेस्ट
कर दिया। ठीक है? यहां पर पेस्ट करने के
बाद ये रहा। सबको दिखाई दे रहा है?
यहां पर रख देता हूं। चलो यहां पे दिख रहा
होगा। उसके बाद जो हमारी काले की मशीन है
उसके ऊपर हम क्या करते हैं? रन करेंगे
हमारे
इसको। एनसी हफ पहले आईपी कॉन्फिग करके देख
लेते हैं।
इफ कॉन्फिग IPपी एड्रेस 119 134 सही है।
करेक्ट
करेक्ट एलएस करते हैं। तो इसको भी हम
डिलीट कर देते हैं। रिमूव फाइल सिस्टम
ऑडिट रिपोर्टxt गुड और अभी हम फ्रेश
स्टार्टअप करेंगे। एक लिसनर ऑन करते हैं
हम। बिल्कुल परफेक्ट
व्हाट ओके
एंड सिस्टम ऑडिट रिपोर्टxt
करना पड़ेगा क्या मुझे?
एंड
देखते हैं। मुझे इसके लिए एक चीज और देखनी
है। वन मोर थिंग व्हाट आई नीड टू डू होल्ड
ऑन ऑन माय नोट्स। आप लोगों के लिए चीज
मुझे देखनी थी।
ओके हम इसके लिए करने वाले हैं। यह रहा
क्योंकि मैं लिटरली बता रहा हूं। सच बोल
रहा हूं क्योंकि मैं आज की क्लास के लिए
बिफोर एक बार भी मैं इसको प्रैक्टिस करके
नहीं आया। ना ही आपको मैं वो करने वाला।
मतलब कि मैं डेमोंस्ट्रेशन पर्पस के लिए
बिल्कुल भी रेडी करके नहीं लेके आया था।
मैं जस्ट रैंडम मैंने कहीं पर नोट डाउन
किया था कि आपको किस चीज के लिए मुझे किस
चीज की रिक्वायरमेंट है। तो जस्ट वही मैं
आपको दिखाने वाला हूं।
और हिट एंटर कर देते हैं। देखते हैं इट
विल वर्क और नॉट। ओके।
एंड यहां पर चलते हैं। डबल क्लिक करते
हैं। ठीक है। डबल क्लिक करते हैं। एंड
इसको मैं ओपन करता हूं।
ओपन किया परफेक्ट अभी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आपको यह
दिखाई दे रहा है सेम पॉपअप ग्लोबल बैंक
आल्सो अब केके इनेबल देखो
कंपाइलेशन एरर है
सेम कुछ तो इशू हर बार हमारे पास पड़ता है
क्योंकि यहां पर इशू है
ऑटो ओपन करने में प्रॉब्लम हो रही है।
अनएक्सेक्टेड हमेशा की तरह।
चलो फिर हम इसको देख भी नहीं पाएंगे अभी।
इसमें क्या है?
ओके आई एम आई एम सीइंग देख रहा हूं देख
रहा हूं देख रहा हूं मैं क्या कर सकता हूं
इसका
जस्ट जस्ट मुझे थोड़ा सा समय दीजिए।
हम एक काम करके देखें तो इसको
हेल्प
हमें नहीं चाहिए। प्रॉब्लम शायद इसमें है।
इसको अगर हम
एक काम करते हैं।
चलो इसको पूरे फंक्शन को हम क्या करते
हैं? कट करते हैं।
ओके।
ओ भाई रुको यार।
एक काम करो। हम पूरे फंक्शन को कट किया
यहां से हमने। और इसको हम क्या कर रहे
हैं? अभी
कहां पर पेस्ट करते हैं? यह अनहाइड फंक्शन
के बाद यह रहा। इसके बाद
ओके ओके। ओके। इसके बाद हम इसको पेस्ट
करते हैं।
यहां पर इसको मैं पेस्ट करता हूं। और यहां
पे इसको और कट करता हूं और इसको यहां पर
इसके बाद
देखते हैं कि अभी क्या इशू आएगा। क्या एरर
आएगी।
देन देखो एंड इसको भी मैं अभी हटा देता
हूं। यह हो गया और आई होप कि अभी कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं आनी चाहिए। हम करते हैं
कंट्रोल एस
रिकॉर्ड डाटा को हम यहां पर अभी हां हम
गलत कर रहे हैं। हां हां कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है। वैसे तो कोई प्रॉब्लम होनी नहीं
चाहिए। फिर भी कंट्रोल एक्स करके यहां पर
कर देते हैं हम रिपोर्ट डाटा को।
नेक्स्ट कंट्रोल s और अभी इसको मैं क्लोज
करता हूं। इस पूरी स्क्रिप्ट को क्लोज
करता हूं। देखो यह यहां पर कुछ फर्क पड़ा
आपको? देखो ध्यान से देखोगे तो यहां पर
कुछ फर्क पड़ेगा।
देखोगे तो ये रहा
और इमेज को क्लोज कर देता हूं। चलो
एंड यहां पर हो गया नेक्स्ट ये हमारा
तुम सबसे पहले बंद हो जाओ। बाकी को बंद हो
ना हो पहले यह सबसे पहले बंद होगा हमारा।
ठीक है? लिसनिंग मोड में ऑन है। नेक्स्ट
राइट क्लिक ओपन किया। ओपन करते देखो अभी
यही आ रहा है। अभी यही आ रहा है क्योंकि
पूरा वह नहीं हो रहा यह अभी। तो इसको पहले
हम अपना कोड रन करते हैं।
और आपका पॉप अप चला गया जो आपको चाहिए था।
ठीक है? अभी हमारा काम कर रहा है। इनेबल
कंटेंट किया। हार्डवेयर की टोकन वेरीिफाइड
ग्लोबल डीआरएम की एक्सचेंज सक्सेसफुली। सो
आल्सो थोड़ा सा और इशू है इसको और क्रैक
करना पड़ेगा। अभी क्या है? एक्सपेक्ट
एक्सपेक्टेड एंड सब कहां पर है प्रॉब्लम?
आपको मैं कैसे दिखाऊं क्योंकि मुझे खुद
नहीं दिख रहा इसमें तो
मैं कोड को थोड़ा थोड़ा सा रिीडफाइन करता
हूं इसको। मुझे लगता है थोड़ा सा रिडफाइन
करना पड़ेगा इसको।
ओम
नहीं यार इसमें कोई इशू ही नहीं है।
हैंडसम
ठीक है मैं एक काम करता हूं अभी
ओम
इकमेंट लोके
कंपाइलेशन एरर एक्सपेक्टेड एंड सब ऑलरेडी
है यहां पर देखो सब एडलाइन सब यहां पर ये
सब सही है आई डोंट नो कि व्हाट इज द इशू
विथ दैट आई एम आल्सो ट्राइंग दैट मैं भी
अब पता करने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं कि हो
क्या रहा है यहां पर
अदर वाइज फिर से वही इशू हुआ आएगा
एक काम करते हैं हम इसको डीबग करके डीबग
होगा
हेल्प ले लेते हैं। चलो
क्या मतलब हो सकता है?
ए आई का यूज़ तो करते हम।
चीज तो वही है लेकिन
लिखा वही है। कुछ अलग से तो नहीं लिखा।
हैंड्स ही है।
फिर से रन करके देख लेते हैं। नो प्रॉब्लम
इधर है। हैंड्स अप क्या करना है?
हमने एक काम किया था। रुको। अभी-अभी हमने
एक चीज डिलीट की थी। अभी-अभी हमने एक चीज
डिलीट की थी। रुको।
इसको मैं क्लोज करता हूं।
प्रोफाइल अभी
ओके
यह था। इसका रिनेम करते हैं पहले
वन।
और इसको हम एक काम करते हैं। रिस्टोर करते
हैं। और मैं इसको रिस्टोर करके
ओपन करके देखूं और मैं यहां पर कुछ टेस्ट
कोड होगा तो आई विल ट्राई।
ये रहा
टेस्ट कोड है यहां पर। टेस्ट कोड
सक्सेसफुली काम किया है।
नो
ये क्या ओपन हो गया?
आई डोंट नो कि कॉइल इज कमिंग आउट।
हम हम हम
दोस्तों
गाइस मुझे लगता है इसको नेक्स्ट क्लास में
ही करना पड़ेगा
क्योंकि आई एम नॉट एबल टू अंडरस्टैंड कि
व्हाट इज द एक्सैक्टली इशू हैपनिंग एक और
काम आप खोल के देखते हो तो यहां पर इसको
काम करते हैं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
क्योंकि यह इस पूरे कोड को वो नहीं करेगा।
फिर भी देख लेते हैं।
उम्मीद तो कम है आप लोगों के हिसाब से।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ये इसको डिलीट कर रहा
यही तो प्रॉब्लम है आप समझ रहे हो
मिलेशियस कोड आपको इसलिए सिखाया जा रहा है
एआई नहीं कोई मदद करने वाला आपकी आपको
क्या लगता है एआई मदद करेगा कोई एआई नहीं
मदद करने वाला एक काम करते हैं
इसको बाहर रखते हैं
एंड इसको बाहर रखेंगे। कहां पर? मेन को से
बाहर। इसको मैं रखता हूं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके।
अभी मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा? पूरे उस कोड
को
हम
मुझे फिर से एनालाइज करना पड़ेगा अच्छे
से।
थैंक यू तो बोलेंगे तो पहले साथ मिलके
उसको क्लियर करते हैं। ओके तो इसको एक काम
करते हैं। अभी क्या आ रही है? ओनली कमेंट
में अपीयर।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इसका इशू ही अलग है।
चलो मैं समझ रहा हूं तुम्हारी बात।
तुम्हारी भी तकलीफ दूर कर देता हूं मैं।
अब सही है। देखते हैं।
ओनली कमेंट
पर अगर मैं इसको बाहर रख दूं अंदर रख दूं
तो सब प्रॉब्लम है।
चलो अभी देख लेते हैं।
ओके अभी कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। वेट वेट
वेट अभी देखते हैं। अभी कोई एरर नहीं आई।
चैट बॉक्स में नहीं आएगी इसको। YouTube वो
कर देगा।
क्यों बैन करना चाहते हो आप मेरे को? फ्री
वाली नौकरी भी पसंद नहीं आ रही आप लोगों
को मेरी।
ठीक है।
अब मुझे तो इस पर इधर मुझे एक और गड़बड़
लग रही है क्योंकि यहां पर हमने कहीं पर
भी कुछ भी मेंशन नहीं किया ऐसे इससे
रिलेटेड तो यहां पर इशू होना स्टार्ट होगा
अभी मैं एक काम करता हूं इसको रन करूं
ओके कॉल आइटम्स वैल्यू नॉट डिफेंड कॉल
आइटम्स यह रहा मिला ना हमने यहां पर
कॉल आइटम
ऐसे मैं बोला था वेरिएबल की बहुत सारी
मिस्टेक मिलेंग जो हमने कट कॉपी पेस्ट में
कर दी है।
[संगीत] एक और मिलेगा
जब हमने इस पे सब पर ध्यान दिया ही नहीं।
एस्केप रिपोर्ट
कितनी छोटी-छोटी सिंटेक्स मिस्टेक्स हमने
की हुई है इसमें। ये रहा
ओके।
अब रिपोर्ट डाटा में क्या इशू आ गया?
कहीं पर हमने मेंशन नहीं किया है।
वेरिएबल नॉट डिफाइंड डिफाइंड द प्रॉब्लम।
तो गाइस मैं एक काम करता हूं।
ठीक है? तो हम इसको नेक्स्ट क्लास में
करते हैं। विद एरर को कंप्लीट करने के बाद
ही आगे फदर क्लास करेंगे। ठीक है? तो इस
सेशन को एंड करते हैं और फालतू का टाइम
वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि एरर आ गई। इस
एरर को हम सॉल्व करेंगे नेक्स्ट क्लास
में। तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में जल्दी लेकर
आऊंगा क्योंकि एरर सॉल्व करते ही तुरंत
आपके हम क्लास स्टार्ट करेंगे और इसका फिर
प्रोफेंसिव साइड भी देखेंगे। उसके अलावा
फिर और कोई अदर टेक्निक है उस टेक्निक को
भी हम कवर करने वाले हैं प्रैक्टिकली। तो
आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट आज के लिए। लेकिन आई
होप कि आज की क्लासेस आपको समझ में आया
होगा जो मैं आपको पढ़ाया होगा। वह तो समझ
में आया होगा।
या नहीं समझ में आया? आज जो पढ़ाया था
कोड दे देंगे यार यहां मैं पेस्ट नहीं कर
सकता। ओके तो आज जो भी कुछ मैंने आपको
पढ़ाया वो सब कुछ समझ में आ गया।
अगर सब कुछ समझ में आ गया तो प्लीज मुझे
बताओ।
आ गया था।
बता दीजिए यार।
यस या नो?
चलिए फिर मैं भेजता हूं। ओके तो चलिए फिर
आज का सेशन एंड करते हैं। बाय-ब एवरीवन
एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन। बाय-ब टेक केयर। सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।